let's say you get an email like this
where it looks like it is from paypal it
says response required really big so
this is a little bit scary and it says
dear you we emailed you a little while
ago to ask you for your help resolving
an issue with your paypal account this
seems really serious your account is
still temporarily limited because we
haven't heard from you we notice some
unusual login activity with your account
please check that no one has logged into
your account without your permission
this is scary to help us with this and
to see what you can and can't do with
your account until the issue is resolved
login to your account or go to the
resolution center as always if you need
help or have any questions feel free to
contact us we're always here to help
thank you for being a paypal customer
sincerely paypal
what would you do in this situation
well i think for a lot of us our
emotional response is hey paypal that's
some of my money is involved there
they're talking about other people maybe
trying to log in i definitely want to
resolve this and just in the heat of the
moment you might click on this login or
you might go to the resolution center
and that might start you down a little
bit of a scary path
because even though this looks like
paypal you really need to verify that it
really is paypal
and there are some clues here that make
it clear that it is not paypal see if
you can find those
well the biggest clue is up here on the
email address
so it says service at
intl.paypal.com as its name but when you
look at the actual email address right
over here notice it actually isn't a
paypal email address it says at
outlook.com
so this is a pretty good clue that this
is not from paypal and so what is this
well this is known as a fishing
attack
why is it called a fishing attack well i
think it's probably based on the idea
that when you're trying to cast catch
fish you dangle some bait for the fish
and you see which fish are going to bite
and so this isn't exactly fishing they
spelled the sound ph because what
they're really doing is they're dangling
some bait in front of you and see if
you're going to metaphorically get your
cheek cut by the fish hook or whatever
happens to fish before they get pulled
out and how would that happen
metaphorically
well when you click on this it probably
goes to this fishy
company or person's website and that
website might look like paypal but it's
not going to be
paypal.com it's going to be some other
web address and so one way to avoid
doing that beyond looking at that this
is a fishy email address
is that in some browsers or in some
email readers you can you can scroll
over this and you'll see what the
website would be or you can right click
on that you could say copy the url and
you could put that in a text document to
see what the actual url is and it's very
likely that that is not going to be a
paypal url in fact i would guarantee you
in this case it would not be it would
look like paypal when you get there what
they'll probably try to get you to do
is type in your username and password
for your paypal account why is that
valuable for them well you just would
have then given them your username and
password for your paypal account which
then they could use to steal money from
you or to do something else to you
so be very careful where you get these
urgent emails or texts i got a text
recently saying that your amazon account
has been compromised click here fast in
order to make sure that no more fraud
happens on your account well it turns
out that the url the web address there
was not amazon.com it was going to take
me to a shady website and that shady
website looked a lot like amazon and so
if i acted really quickly i would have
given them my amazon username and
password
so be on the lookout for these phishing
attacks and the main way to catch them
is be skeptical of anything that's
talking about fraud about
something that you would scare you and
say hey is do i really think this is
happening and then if you really think
it might be happening verify the email
addresses verify the web addresses that
they're really coming from who they say
they're from and it doesn't matter if
the name is at somethingpaypal.com you
have to look at the actual email address
it doesn't matter what it says here it
matters what the actual url is that it
clicks to to make sure that it isn't
fishy no pun intended or actually that
pun was intended